hi everyone welcome back to another q a
video where i'll be asking
or i'll be answering rather your
questions and this time i'm actually
including all of my subscribers
so i'll be answering all of your
questions not just my patrons although
of course as always my patrons will be
getting
the priority here so i will be answering
their questions first
and then because i got so many questions
on my last post
i won't be able to answer all of them
obviously so i'll pick a few ones
out and i'll do my best to answer them
for you
now before we start i would just like to
say that
amazingly this channel has grown quite a
bit recently
we just a few weeks ago reached 10 000
subscribers and before i even had time
to
blink or make a video thanking you for
that
suddenly we're now at 25 000 subscribers
that's
just absolutely amazing i'm very humbled
and thankful
that so many of you seem to be enjoying
the content
that you are maybe spreading the content
that you
support me in various ways especially of
course i would like to thank my patrons
who support me over on patreon
this is as i've said in most my videos
this is really what's keeping this
channel
going um you know i'm working a
full-time job i'm
doing these videos at the same time i
have a bunch of other projects so
this is of course very time consuming
even though it is something that i'm
very passionate about but
the fact that you guys support me so
that i am able to buy the books
for research or to all kinds of
different things that i need to make
these videos that is just
incredible to me that you choose to
support me and i'm
very humbled and so thankful for that so
thank you everyone for getting us to
this place
and i look forward to
keep making videos and and keep growing
this channel
as we go forward so as i said i'll begin
by answering the questions asked by my
patrons
so first of all uh yasir khan asks
what which thinker philosopher sufi or
religious figure that you have come
across
in your studies inspires you most
hmm i don't know i mean
i mean most of them inspire me in some
way i guess
a lot of these people are inspiring in a
lot of ways
none of them are perfect of course
there's not a single person i think is
you know the perfect person to to
emulate in any way i don't know really
who do i
admire the most i think i've been asked
this question before
like which philosopher do i like the
most and i really don't have
an answer for that i tend to like
philosophers who
do you know put a lot of weight to
reason
and and and rationality i'm quite a
sort of personally i'm a person who
relies a lot on on reason
and logic but i am also the kind of
person who
who is very adamant to recognize the
limits of our intellect and of reason
and so i guess i tend to sympathize with
the philosophers
who do put an emphasis on reason but to
a degree
and then sort of agree that well after
that
something else will have to to take over
um you know philosophers like you
even to fail or even sabain are examples
of those kinds of philosophers i think
generally
people i'm not so much inspired or
impressed by
people's intelligence or how
complex their metaphysics are usually i
think what inspires me
and what i admire the most in people
historically or today is
is rather what kind of a person they are
in terms of
you know if they're kind loving if
they're humble
so these kinds of things so i don't know
if i can just
come up with someone off the top of my
head but people
in history or today that showcases
humbleness
and kindness and a sort of loving
attitude towards
fellow human beings and other creatures
generally
those are the people that inspire me the
most okay hanan
fikri asks according to
is creation an extension of god if not
then does that mean that creation always
existed
with the existence of god uh saying that
it's an extension of god seems to imply
that it's somehow
part of god and this is not what
teaches at least teaches
to him the world or creation is a
manifestation of god it's a
manifestation of his divine attributes
like a mirror but it's also
they take their existence from god's
existence so
it's that's the relationship that it has
that these two have god in the world
um it's not so much that it is a part of
the world like a part of god's body or
something like that that's that's
uh that's not how uh
should be understood um and when it
comes to the
eternity of the world uh ibn adabi was
not in favor of the idea of
the world's eternity um you know some of
those who have
been fans of him who have been abscribed
to the idea of
that has
interpreted it in a way that allows for
the eternity of the world
but generally i think that school does
not
tend to hold this idea the eternity of
the world is more commonly found in some
of the
uh peripatetic philosophers like ibn
cena and ibn rushd al-farabi
who would often indeed argue that the
world was eternal
with god and yet that he was the creator
of them
even cena uses a lot of great allegories
to explain how this
works but in terms of no
that's i would not say that this is the
case okay mikhail stankiewicz asks maybe
you could say something about trends in
religious studies
and which ones inspire the most stuff
like eliad everything is connected and
the opposite views
which ones were significantly more
present in your university education
than others
so the place i studied was is a
university called so the turn university
in stockholm sweden
and the program there the culture there
is sort of very inspired by
you say post-modernist thinking as well
as a lot of post-colonial
theories theories post-orientalist
attitudes um
and so because i'm taught in that
environment
i have a lot of that stuff in me
obviously it's funny when people
accuse me and many others for being
orientalists i think i feel like people
use the word orientalist so much as a
critique that has lost all its meaning
a lot of what we do where i come from is
to actually study
the orientalists which would be the old
sort of colonial
scholars who often had an incredibly
biased view of the middle east
and a huge part of
the studies of religion today where i
come from
is to look at those scholars and try to
undo what they have messed up
in the past so orientalist for us too
is a very negative term and something
that we basically strive very hard to go
against
and some people keep calling me and
others orientalists just because we are
i don't know because we're scholars from
the west um
or white scholars or white scholars who
those people particularly don't agree
with on a certain subject
then we're all orientalists um
in any case um there's a lot of stuff
that we
about the kind of culture where my
educational
context um i've always been a fan of the
more sociological perspectives on
religion you know
durkheim and his kind of school religion
is primarily a social phenomenon
it's about you know group belonging
about about
personal identity and things like this
but there's a lot of really fascinating
stuff
research being done also about uh
psychological
uh theories on religion like cognitive
behavioral theories about how that
affects our view of the world and why we
believe in gods and things like this
so there's a lot going on i think all of
them have
great things to teach and take a lot of
good ideas from different
theories and different schools and i
think that was one of the things that
that my educational circumstances were
very good for which was that we of
course study
all different kinds of theories and
perspectives on religion
you know academically so it's been a
it's been a melting pot of a lot of
different things dan hill says
i see you've covered coffee i wonder if
it would be appropriate to discuss
cannabis yes it's always appropriate to
discuss cannabis
um on a serious note i think
um this is of course something that
there's a lot to be said about and i
will be tackling this in the future i
think i got some other
question from uh subscriber also about
talking about the use of psychedelics
and sufism for example
so so yeah i will probably be tackling
that subject uh
pretty soon i hope lastly from my patron
team
is matija kurbanovic excuse the
pronunciation
do you plan to cover the is it bone or
burn religion one day
uh i'll be honest my knowledge about
this religion is
very limited i have even had to
google it right now to you know of
course i've heard of it but i had to
google it to remember what it actually
was
um even though you know as a you know i
hate that word but
as a scholar of religions i obviously
don't know everything
and this is definitely a a gap in in my
in my knowledge but that's a good thing
because that just means i have a lot of
fascinating research ahead of me so
yes i would love to cover that at some
point okay so questions from my
regular subscribers um
number one from fatima safa studying
what religion had the most
impact on your life i don't think any of
them had a
more of an impact on my life than any
other um i've studied islam and sufism
more than other religions so maybe just
by that fact that has had a huge impact
on me
but other than that i don't think there
is one who
you know has impacted me more than any
other really
okay safe king 35 asks what religion do
you practice
and this is of course one of the most
frequently asked questions what religion
do i belong to what do i believe in am i
muslim
no first of all no i'm not a muslim
what religion do i practice uh i
and what religion do i belong to i might
as well answer all these questions at
the same time i
consider myself culturally to be
christian but i don't necessarily adhere
to the
um theological doctrines of the trinity
and these things so on that basis maybe
i wouldn't be considered a christian
by many other than that i don't really
adhere to
any specific religion at all at the
moment
i've said previously that i i do believe
in god
it depends of course on how you define
god but generally when people ask me do
you believe in god i'll say yes
and and i do have a way of
relating to that i do have a way of
practicing but it's not related to any
specific
religion in that sense not at the moment
who knows where life takes you right but
right now i don't belong to any specific
religion in that sense so here's another
very
common question one of the most
frequently asked answered
most frequently asked question um
in this post which is what do you think
of the perennial philosophy
and such figures as rene guenon and
fitzger schwann
many people asked questions relating to
this
so the perennial philosophy or the
perennial school
is a school of philosophy
that emerged for the most part in the
20th century and it's associated with
these thinkers that he mentioned
renegade going on
and friction also said jose nasser and
many others
very influential of course especially in
scholarship about
sufism they have been very prominent as
as
some of the greatest and most successful
scholars and writers about sufi topics
and the preamble philosophy is basically
this idea that
many of the world's religions like islam
christianity
hinduism buddhism has certain
core features or essential features that
are
the same even though they're expressed
in different languages that's a very
simplified way of explaining
it but but that's the sort of perennial
idea this idea of perennial wisdom
throughout the world's religions
i think they have certainly they have
some very interesting ideas
i am you know my academic side
is a little skeptical because i think
of course we can find a lot of
similarities between religions but there
are also a lot of differences
just like you know the theories of
carl jung or some of his
people from his school also tends to
often
i think simplify things to a large
degree and and
connect certain traditions and ideas
from
different cultures that aren't
necessarily the same thing but they only
become
the same thing in the mind of the person
who is theorizing about it
but you know at the same time i have a
lot of perennial
tendencies myself you know when i talk
about
abnorbi and myself eckhart and adi
shankara and the taoist writers
like there's a you know it's hard to
deny
that somewhat the things they say are
just
fascinatingly similar to each other and
that there are certain features of these
different religions that
sometimes seem to be completely
unconnected to each other
that have these very strong features and
similarities to them
and i am endlessly fascinated by that
stuff too and i love to talk about
why that may be why is ibn alabi and
maestro record so similar
is it because of a common influence from
neoplatonism for example or is it some
common human experience that they're
both trying to grab at i don't know
obviously but i think it's just so
fascinating to
to think about when it comes to the idea
of the perennial philosophy this is
something that i will be talking about
more
i'll be i'm planning on making videos on
that in the future so i'll be
talking about that more deeply later on
so i'll keep this
pretty short now but yeah so you can
look forward to me talking about that
more in the future
ahmed bd asks which religion impressed
you the most
no in religion has really impressed me
more than any other
dortoka says outside of youtube and
learning what are your favorite
hobbies well i do i am a musician
so i play music that's a
huge part of my identity i guess
i that was my primary primary occupation
and
well primary activity
before this channel started to gain some
traction so to say
and that's still a huge part of my life
i have a lot of different hobbies and
interests i also studied film for a
while which is very helpful when i make
these youtube videos
just arts and culture culture
generally is something that always
fascinates me so you know even though
i'm not good at it you know i love
visual art like painting poetry
again this is not something that i do
myself but i very much enjoy
that watching movies um yeah
you know i i've never been into sports
or cars but other than that like i i'm
basically interested in anything that
you
you know put in front of me uh benali
bader asks did sufis ever use
psychedelics probably
um there are evidence uh
or you know it's pretty well known that
many sufis historically used
substances like well cannabis for
example
uh and opium i haven't heard any direct
prefaces to
you know mushrooms or things like that
depends on what you count as
psychedelics but certainly
cannabis and opium and things like this
have been consumed
by sufis as a way to help them in their
spiritual practices
we know this for example because of
people
who say for example the founder of the
numatullahi
sufi order nima ali
he's famous for one of the things that
he taught
was that he told his students to not
or to stop smoking
cannabis right so this tells us that
there were suffice who did
because otherwise he wouldn't have to
tell them not to so yes there are
there are evidence that this is
something that took place aliram asks
what videos are you planning to do next
for the two for the for the next two
months
would you consider traveling to places
to study more about the topics you made
videos about
um i have different things planned i'm
working on a video about
meister eckhart which is a great
christian theologian and mystic of the
middle ages
i am also planning to do one on abu
lafia which is a jewish
catalyst and mystic also
i am working on some stuff on islamic
occultism and
magic i am doing some more on
hinduism delving into some of those
schools that i talked about in the last
video
yeah i have a bunch of different ideas
but those are some of the ones that i'm
working on
currently matthias yeah oh
graziac excuse me asks what religious or
philosophical text is dearest to you
why do you always ask me to take sites
like this i don't i don't
know there is a lot of beauty and wisdom
in so many of these texts
i think i revealed the secret that i
very much love
the text called drunza which is a taoist
text
i've always just absolutely loved that
one i there are certain
books of the bible that i'm very fond of
i love the book of job i also love the
book of ecclesiastes for example
there are certain surahs in the quran
that are absolutely beautiful
yeah there's there's a lot of stuff
those are the ones that
just at the top of my head that i can
think about but i see value in most
of those kinds of texts there is always
something to be learned
or to to to be inspired by i think when
you read these
old texts i think they have survived for
so long as
important texts for a reason um and so
for that reason alone there is usually
something in there
to to to learn from issa asks
or says i appreciate that you share the
original arabic terms for many topics
and your pronunciations are quite good
thank you very much do you speak arabic
fluently
no i wouldn't say fluently but i have
studied arabic
officially at university for a year
which of course is nothing when it comes
to arabic
but it's enough that i have a general
grasp of
the grammar and the basics of the
language i can
read and write and speak arabic but not
to the degree that i would be able to
hold a conversation with someone for
example
and i basically only know fusa which is
classical
or modern standard arabic and not really
any
of the dialects and a little iraqi
dialect because my wife's family is from
iraq but other than that like
no so i i want to
of course increase my knowledge in
arabic but that's where i stand at the
moment
okay you seem
like always have a superb list of
sources to dig deeper before
the video making how do you choose your
sources to learn
primarily read so a few people have
asked this question too where do i get
my sources from
um so my criterium for sources is that
they are scholarly sources
so that they are scientific sources and
peer-reviewed
academic sources so i get a lot of the
kind of comments that will say that you
know
i should be you know why am i using
western scholars as
you know sources and not muslim scholars
or islamic scholars
it's not that i'm not using islamic
scholars if you look through
these sources there's always a list to
begin with
there is always a list of sources in the
descriptions of my videos if you want to
see where i get my sources from or you
want to you know find
things to read yourself but i also see a
lot of people
criticizing that i use
non-muslim sources that's not
necessarily the case a lot of the
sources i use is by muslims
the fact they're muslim or not does not
make a difference to me the difference
is if they're
scholarly if they're scientific if
they're academic if they are
you know objective at least as objective
as possible
um that they are operating from within
an academic
context which makes them scientifically
reliable i am not interested in using
polemical texts as
sources you know certain my videos are
made on shia islam or ibadi islam people
have said that i
should you know look into islamic
sources and what they say but
you know if i were to only look at sunni
sources for describing
shia islam that would be ridiculous i do
take sources from many different places
if i'm
writing about a certain philosophy for a
person i always try to read
their own words if i'm if i want to
represent them
properly and if i'm writing about a
certain religious group i'll try to get
the perspective of
that religious group but
not necessarily from groups who are
critical of them
that's so my when i made my video on
manichaeism for example i did not rely
on
christian sources or you know as in like
medieval
polemical christian sources or muslim
sources because honestly they are
usually not reliable because they're
polemical they're critical
so it's much better to rely on you know
sources from
inside that tradition itself or from
you know academic scholarly scientific
sources jennifer grove asked how many
different traditions
did the platonic philosophy get around
to influencing and
when oh boy um
you know platonism obviously
one of the most probably the most
well at least one of the most
influential philosophical schools of
all time there is this saying that
all philosophy al well all western
philosophy
problematic term of course but this is
how the saying goes all western
philosophy are basically footnotes to
plato
and there is something to that statement
because plato is such a
foundational figure for all of the
traditions that follow to some degree
who were either followers of him or at
least commented on him to some degree
platonism is a hugely important for
some of the world's major religions
christianity islam
also certain forms of judaism and many
others
like central ideas in these religions
like the fact
there's a soul like the soul that is
separate from the body
very platonic idea so the influence of
plato can really not
be overstated when well all the time
um yeah plato very very influential
abdul rahman shokri asks why are you
hiding your beliefs while you are doing
a channel about religions
i think we have to know from which
perspective you are viewing at
other religions i i don't think i'm
hiding my beliefs
you know maybe they just don't shine
through that much i always try to keep
the content on this channel as unbiased
as possible
as objective as possible now
you know i also recognize that it's
impossible to be completely objective
it's impossible to be completely
unbiased
my personal views whatever they may be
on a subject will always shine
through in some way so when i talk about
a subject you'll
probably notice in some way if i'm
excited about it or not for example
but i don't think i hide my religious
identity
i've already talked about in this video
that i don't really
know ascribe very much to a certain
religious identity
uh consciously so and so
it's not something that i consciously
hide it's just that this is the way i've
been also taught to talk about religions
from
this unbiased and an academic
perspective and that's what i do at
on this channel this is not a religious
channel i am not
you know i'm not a religious scholar i'm
a scholar of religion
there's a difference there right so i'm
not here to to talk about who is right
or who's wrong or
what religion is better than some other
religion i'm just here to talk about
religions as they are
from an academic perspective well that's
that's the purpose of this channel to
not
let those things affect what i say the
most what i think what
uh what what annoys me with this kind of
question you know
i'm not annoyed with you specifically of
course but
this seems to be this underlying feeling
that
when people ask me are you muslim or
what perspective do you view this from
it's like they're trying to
check if they can trust me right well
they need to they need to know which
perspective
i am talking from so they can know that
you know if they agree with that
perspective they can know if they can
you know trust me or not if my knowledge
is is worth listening to
and so i think that's not the way i like
to look at things i'd like to
examine ideas as they are
of course people's opinions and
perspectives are going to play a part in
that
and i get the idea that knowing what
perspective a certain person is talking
from
is helpful and we try to do this as much
as possible as academics as well at
least in the
modern or post-modern perspective that's
part partly what i think that whole
thing is about is to be self-reflexive
to to realize that our personal
biases and personal opinions and stances
on things my background my nationality
my upbringing everything will affect
what i do academically if i'm doing i'm
writing a paper
i'm doing some research project or if
i'm doing a youtube video
my personal opinions are always going to
be there they can't be completely just
shoved under the rug that's that's
impossible that's the mistake that a lot
of
the you know scholars of the earlier
20th century made for example
and what we try to do today is to be
self-conscious about our background and
our biases
and be open about them and try to see
you know
how do these influence our research and
what can we do about it
so if it seems to you that i am hiding
my religious identity
or my beliefs then i guess i am not
doing my job
properly in a way because i think that's
important for us to be
a transparent even as academics um
but that it's not something i do
consciously at
all i think it's just just a natural
result of
my sort of very
neutral stance on on this subject
generally
dc asks does religion justify preeminent
violence
which religion um no
yes and no i mean look as i said in my
videos about
um essentialism religions don't really
do anything or
you know it's people who do things and
there are
always different people in different
religions so when it comes to things
like
you know violence does religion support
violence does christianity support
violence do islam support violence no
yes and no but the religion itself
doesn't it's the people who do
certain christians do certain christians
don't for example
so to say something that generalizing
about just a religion
i think is is is unhelpful
um so yeah that's my
sort of cop-out answer for that question
so last question for today
pat the rao asked what will you see what
do you see the future of religion being
will it continue to fade away
generation after generation or will it
forever be part of human identity
um you know it depends on how you define
religion
generally i don't think religion's going
anytime anywhere anytime soon
um you know the research shows that
in one sense religion is
declining at least it was a couple of
decades ago
but what that means is that the big
religious
institutions like you know the christian
church and then
you know the big religions right are to
some degree decreasing in in numbers and
popularity that the
this group called the nuns that is not
affiliated
is one of the fastest rising groups of
or demographics in the world today
but at the same time that does not mean
that people have stopped believing
in things associated with religious
beliefs believing in an afterlife and
god or gods um magic or
any of these things right and of course
a lot of new religious movements
uh are also becoming increasingly
popular so
um even though maybe some of the big
religions or i think let's put it like
this i think
it's possible that religion as we know
it
is changing or that religion as we know
it
might be decreasing in popularity it's
not going to go away
anytime soon at all but that
what that means is that it's only going
to take new forms i think
it is some kind of human trait some kind
of human
maybe not need but but it's a very human
thing
to have these kinds of things have these
beliefs have these rituals
and to relate to the world or the
universe and our fellow men
in a kind of structured and organized
way
some religion often offers so i think
i don't think religion defined in a
broad sense is going anywhere i think
that's very much something that is
part of a human nature that will stay
that way
but that maybe you know the religious
big religions or religions as we know it
might um not be as prominent in the
future as they are now but
that's very hard to say because a lot of
other research also shows that
religion has become more popular and
more prominent in society in the last
few decades
so i don't know i think these things
fluctuate a lot
we'll see you know i'll maybe i'll
probably make some videos on subjects
like this
when i'm more prepared to talk about it
more more
fully researched so that was last
question
uh thank you all so much for asking your
question this was a lot of fun i'd love
to do this more in the future
i know there was one question or one
person asked when am i when am i doing a
live stream
q a i don't know uh
that sounds like a fun idea i would love
to do some live streams in the future
um i'll just have to you know make some
time for it because right now my
my schedule is quite f packed
uh but yeah that's also something i'm
looking forward to doing in the future
and uh yeah i'll see you in the comments
and thank you all so much again for
your support and for subscribing and for
getting this channel to
what is now 25 000 subscribers
it's uh yeah that's just crazy uh thank
you so much again
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you